[Music]
of ages you you are starting this movie
opposite Tom Cruise you have some who's
that again Tom Cruise oh yeah oh yeah
yeah yeah yeah big big star he you have
an insane kiss with Tom Cruise in this
movie I don't even know if you can call
it a kiss it's like a lick fest it's
like two dogs just going crazy I mean
Adam Shankman literally just said that's
the director he told you that's the
director just said like why don't you
guys just like just go to the point
where you're like licking her eyeballs
like I want it to be the tiniest tongue
kiss of all time so you guys did that
yeah what we did yeah all right we have
a clip here is yeah I don't believe that
clip I don't think this is the kiss okay
I have to hide by in this chair no no no
but I believe is this a scene where
you're interviewing Tom Cruise I think
it's yes it is so I'm I am actually a
Rolling Stones journalist who comes in
with a lot of integrity and leaves
without any um but but yeah it's he's
sort of like a like a washed-up rock
star and doesn't really want to do the
interview and I of course want to get a
great story but he's being a bit of a
[ __ ] so okay yeah the rock star is not
actually Tom Cruise no no uh let's make
that clear I don't want to be here uh
we'll sing with this clip from Rock of
Ages when you think of blubber blah and
blah blah blah you make sure that you
want to take in huh have four minutes
you know some people have said that
you've become quite difficult to work
with that you're constantly late you're
reclusive sometimes even nonsensical
well I ask you this have these people
even met themselves
well I'm talking about your band
[Applause]